i've been a therapist for 35 years i
worked with millionaires and movie stars
and i realized they have the same
problem i just didn't feel enough
britain's number one hypnotherapist the
founder of rapid transformation therapy
best-selling author marissa pierce
people who are depressed have a very
interesting belief one is there's no
cure you know it's genetic and even if
there was it wouldn't work for me can
you change that belief very quickly yeah
but you have to take a look at where did
this happen how does one go about
identifying which of these stories are
the root cause well i think the first
thing is
you must also face some pretty
heartbreaking cases tell me about one
that comes to mind when i say that i
think my saddest case was a boy of 14
whose father was hitting him with a belt
nobody needs that
oh just excuse me for one minute nice
[Music]
it's no one's job to make you feel good
it's your job and if you give someone
the job of making you feel good then
guess what you give them the job of
making you feel bad if you can give
yourself the certainty you're looking
for instead of looking for it somewhere
else the shift isn't subtle it's
profound
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
direva ceo usa edition i hope nobody's
listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
marissa
first and foremost thank you for being
here as you will know i'm a big fan of
your work i included much of sort of
something really pertinent
that you'd said in my book as well i
think that's how we kind of came became
connected um you spend so long helping
other people and understanding them
i wanted to start today by understanding
you a little bit okay i want to go right
back i know that so i did a little bit
of childhood psychology as well and
that's this is why your work is
particularly resonant with me but take
me back to your childhood i read this
this quote you'd said which i thought
might be a good stage setter which was
when i was growing up i struggled with
the belief that i wasn't enough this
belief followed me through my teens and
right into my twenties
yes certainly did
so who was that child
well you know i had an interesting
childhood later someone in therapy said
my god your childhood sounded absolutely
crazy but it wasn't crazy but it was
interesting i had a very beautiful
mother
who was
deeply deeply unfulfilled beauty meant
gave her nothing she she wasn't a woman
who could stay at home and be a mother i
had a father who was deeply deeply
intellectual he was a head teacher
and he loved his career and it was
interesting watching this stranger my
father loved his career he helped kids
every day he gave my gave himself to my
mother was totally unfulfilled always
ill a little bit hysterical
and
i watched that and i remember thinking
you know what you have to have a great
job you've got to get a job that's
compelling and engrossing because it
protects you from the pain it wasn't if
there's pain it was there's going to be
pain
my parents relationship was a car crash
but if you've got an amazing career
then you'll be okay so i always wanted
something engrossing and fulfilling but
my father was very interested in other
people's children because they were
easier to work with than his own so it
was certainly
an interesting life but i don't regret
any of it because it gave me the
ambition to also think wow you can help
you my father's stories say helping
people is what life is all about because
it was for him
he wasn't very good at helping my poor
mother but that's okay
so
it was i know but there were lots of
elements of my life that were strange so
for instance i felt different i was the
head teacher's daughter and i went to
his school
and i realized later that is the bane of
people's lives to be different because
we're all hardwired from birth to find
connection
and avoid rejection when you feel
different then
that can be really really strange but it
made me understand human psychology very
early on what it's like to be different
what it's like to not fit in what it's
like when
it looks perfect on the outside it's not
really like that on the inside
so it stood me in very good stead i
think my childhood was the perfect
background to be a therapist
and where did you
in hindsight pick up the belief that you
weren't enough
yeah you know i remember being in my
father's school and he actually was my
history he wrote in my history book i
think i was 11 i remember to this day he
said oh this is amazing work i had no
idea you're intelligent and i think he
wrote that to please me but i was not
pleased i'm ever thinking well my father
doesn't even know who i am
and so
the not enoughness came from
living with a father who was invested in
other people's children living with a
mother who was always in hospital
living with a brother who was very
clever went to pride both my sister and
brother went to private school and i
didn't because i wasn't the smart one
and my sister was a cute little
beautiful little baby my brother was the
firstborn smart boy and i just felt like
this thing this kind of freak if you
like in the middle but now i'm glad
about that because
it gave me that that understanding but i
did have one thing i had a grandmother
who really believed in me thought i was
a genius i remember thinking then
that's actually all you need one person
when i became a therapist i'd work with
a lot of
i always from the lost boys like 15 year
old kids who were so angry and they they
say no one believes me i said that's not
true i believe in you
and you can believe in you that's
already two people and i've always
believed that if you have one
person to believe in you your life can
be amazing so i always had my
grandmother she lived 300 miles away but
she really believed in me
and at that age what did you want to do
with your life did you have a hypothesis
or a vision so i wanted to be an artist
i was very good at art my daughter's now
an amazing artist but i wanted to be an
artist and i was like no no you can't be
an artist you can't go to art school
that's just for druggies and drop outs i
still love illustrating and i was always
writing stories which is quite funny now
because i wrote stories my mother kept
them all they were always about
dysfunctional families
and unhappy families and that was so
interesting that i wrote that now of
course
i write i wrote that book's all about
the stories of unhappy people
so i always thought i'd be an artist and
my father said you should be a teacher
like me that would be amazing for you so
i went to teach a training college you
know i'd love to be a teacher
but then i realized that i didn't want
to be a teacher after all so
i left that and went off to work for
jane fonda here in la which was much
more fun
and i loved that i went fully into the
diet weight loss fitness industry
but even then i realized how abusive
that industry is how cruel it is to
people how it tells them that your worth
is entirely judged on the number on the
scales or the number on the tape measure
and i saw working for jane that
you know anorexia and bulimia mental
illnesses body dysmorphic is a mental
illness they were trying to cure it with
aerobics
and living on protein shakes and diet
soups
and so then i came across this wonderful
guy called gil boy and he was a
hypnotist and i trained with him and
thought well this is amazing i've got
all these people i'm teaching aerobics
in the 80s it was a huge thing every day
and my classes wore with anorexics
bulimics body dysmorphics exercise
compulsives orthorexics which are people
who only eat clean organic food and i
thought well i didn't even have to
advertise for clients and i didn't
and so then i had this amazing life
teaching for jane during the day
seeing clients
in the evening but then i got so busy i
had to actually stop working for her
because i just couldn't cope with the um
amount of clients that were coming
through my door because i found
something
that really fixed eating disorders and
that was such an amazing thing and you
meet gil boyne when you girlboyne isn't
it yeah girlborn when you got to
l.a yeah and
you talk about this individual being a
really pivotal yeah he was a
hypnotherapist yeah he was and what was
it about him and what he taught you that
stayed with you you know gil was one of
the people i loved the most he broke all
the rules he swore like a trooper he
banged his fist on the table but he was
deeply deeply religious believe that god
worked through him he was just such a
fascinating character because he was a
street fighter from philadelphia
who worked with sylvester stallone and
hypnotized him to write rocky
and realized he was onto something and
then developed this amazing school
teaching hypnotherapists and he so
believed in it that he would guarantee
that if he trained you and somebody sued
you he would turn up in court and defend
you and pay all the costs which
stands different from phenomenal beliefs
i trained with him
and then i became a hypnotherapist and i
loved it and then over time he did ask
me at once if i wanted to as he got
older and retired run his business by
then i'd found my own method my own
technique i always think that when you
train to be a therapist any kind of
therapist
no matter how amazing your teacher is
and i now teach amazing therapists but
you have another teacher every client
you see will teach you something
profound and amazing so then my own
clients became my teachers and taught me
so much and they'd come back you know
that one thing you did that changed my
life that one thing you said oh my god
that was a game changer so i started to
collate the one thing which is different
of course for every client they never
all said the same thing
and then collating the one thing
that
gave them a stunning turnaround i then
created my own method which i called
rapid
transformational therapy people say but
that's not right the words therapy and
rapid don't go together why well
it has to be long and painful who said
that
if i turned up i did turn up at er once
i broke my arm
and they didn't say well we've got to
build a relationship of trust to heal
you i didn't go to my dentist you know
i've got an infection here they were
well we need the trust you see
and i always thought people in pain
emotional pain is no different to
physical pain
if i've got a headache or a broken arm
i've got irritable bowel or
blushing i can't find love or i stutter
that's really painful
and i thought that therapy should be
like going to the emergency room that we
should offer immediate help
so much of the um
the underlying thesis about you know in
your new book and i guess behind your
rapid transformational therapy is this
idea that there's stories that are
within us that are yeah from our
childhood or whatever and they are
sometimes and often very stubborn
stories so imagine
as you've said the reason why people
think it's hard for it to be rapid or
quick is because those stories are so
deeply ingrained and stubborn and etched
into us
and we make someone else's story our
story my mom always wanted a boy i was
the fourth girl my dad wanted me to go
into the family law firm
but i i wasn't smart and so
i see two things a lot someone else's
story my mum said don't even trust your
own shadow
but that's not your story that's someone
else's story
so the first problem is that we make
somebody else's story my teacher said
i'd never amount to anything it's that's
not your story my teacher said that to
me
but that wasn't my story but the second
thing that's even more painful are
the lies we tell ourselves and
the biggest lies i'm not enough i'm not
lovable
i don't matter and
what happens with small children is they
come into the world they don't actually
have a lot of needs they need to feel
safe
loved significant
they need to feel they matter but when
you're a small child if your parents
cannot meet those needs because they're
alcoholics they're mentally ill
they're doing three jobs they're a
single parent they're stressed or
whatever it is
the child never stops loving them they
immediately stop loving themselves if
only i was better my mum wouldn't be
crying if only i was good my dad
wouldn't shout if only i was something
my dad would see me at the weekends
and once they buy into that oh it's my
fault
that becomes a lifelong sentence but
it's very easy to unpick that by saying
to us look you know
you're looking at this through the
filter of a five-year-old
one of my clients told me that she was
walking with her mother in ireland and
her father's friend come and he said
it's a disgrace that you haven't given
your husband a son he'll never be a man
you know because he doesn't have a son
what a strange thing for him to say but
this little girl heard that and thought
oh i should have been a boy
my i've caused both my parents this
tremendous grief and then she became
very masculine she worked as a fire
officer
in fact she was head of a fire crew
and she wouldn't wear makeup she
wouldn't let her husband put up a shelf
she had very short hair and and that was
okay except she said i feel very
conflicted because i just can't be the
person i want to be
and i feel like i've got to do
everything perfectly and my husband i
have so many arguments that i want to
drive the car i'll pack i'll carry
everything
and just going back to remember that
scene was a real aha moment oh
i heard something at five your husband
will never be a man because he hasn't
got a son that last child should have
been a son
but you see she interpreted it with the
mind of a five-year-old
at 35 take a look again
and maybe understand that you were meant
to be a girl your father was thrilled to
be a girl and even if you wanted a boy
somebody
wanted you to be a girl so we see things
with the filter of a child he's been on
the planet for four years what do they
know
i'm not good enough i'm not lovable
i i was a disappointment so
looking at it again as an adult you get
the chance to say oh i see
i believed something then that felt true
but it wasn't true
can that change in beliefs be rapid
though so say yeah in that case that can
be a really rapid yeah i don't know if
you read the case about ryan the
alcoholic whose
father rejected him because he was gay
and he always felt
so sad he attracted men that were
abusive to him
and when he when i had him have an
imaginary conversation with his dad he
said i feel inadequate
when i had a gay son i just felt more
inadequate it's not you it's me he began
to realize that he wasn't a broken
person at all but he had broken
parenting and i think i said that to him
ryan you're not broken but your
parenting was broken you're not flawed
but you had flawed parenting but there's
a huge difference you are not flawed
but your parents who were young and his
mother got pregnant they weren't suited
you had a flawed upbringing but there's
a huge difference and then he was able
to make his peace with that and stop
drinking completely he's never had a
drink since so
if you think therapy is long it can be
like that if you can look at a scene and
reframing go oh
i thought that but that wasn't even true
then it becomes a game changer and it
can take 21 days for the launch it can
take 21 seconds if you can look at
something oh i see i thought that
but actually that was an incorrect
thought and i can go back and correct an
incorrect thought
if at the
um the crux of our lives and our
behavior exists these like fundamental
self stories we've told ourselves about
ourselves about who we are and about
where we our significance in the world
etc how does one go about even
identifying unless they have a wonderful
therapist how do they go about
identifying which of these stories are
the um
root cause of the symptoms they're
seeing in their lives whether it's
addiction depression anxiety whatever it
might be
well i think the first thing is is you
know just start to observe your thoughts
do you have those what i call limiting
thoughts i'm not enough who's going to
want me i'm not lovable
no one cares about me
and think about the thoughts and then
ask yourself a question where did this
thought come from no baby is okay don't
look at me i'm naked i've got no teeth
i've got milk so i've got these triple
knees here and i'm not enough
so what happened to that belief well
someone chipped away at it a parent
a relative a teacher somebody
and because children are so suggestible
it's very easy to make them think
they're not enough
but can you change that belief very
quickly yeah but you have to take a look
at where did this happen
you know i never said well what's wrong
with you i say what happened to they go
well
i was a perfectly normal weight until i
was 11. and then what happened well i
went to school i got bullied
people started to make really weird
sexual comments about my body and i just
got fatter and fatter and then they
never did that again
so now we see oh so somehow what was
happening
had a role and a function and every
thought you think isn't a thought it's a
blueprint
that your mind body and psyche work to
make real i think if you take a thought
you know for me i was always late as a
kid for everything i missed the bus to
school every day and as an adult i was
always late if i had 10 hours to get
somewhere i'd be i missed planes i
missed appointments
and one day i suddenly realized that
when i was a kid and i missed the bus to
school my father i'd have to walk home
he'd be furious he wouldn't even speak
would he get out the car
and drive me in silence to my school's
three-mile drive i never missed the bus
coming home by the way then i thought oh
of course i did that for attention
but my father is now deeply proud of me
and even if he wasn't
i don't need that attention being like
and it just stopped like that
because i suddenly saw the role of it
the job the function
and many times if you can just ask
yourself if this headache or this
blushing or this asthma or this
feeling had a
job or was trying to help me what would
it do and
it's really amazing the answers that
come up
is that why you say um
when you think about the sort of the
core principle of rtt it says don't just
treat the behavior treat the purpose the
is always treat the purpose you see if
someone what does that mean how do i
make well let's imagine that you you
binge on cakes or you're the kind of
person when something goes wrong you you
eat pizza or a cake or something and
most of us go tell you what's wrong with
that but i say hey what's right with it
you're an alcoholic tell me what's good
about that what do you mean well you
keep going back to it and they go
actually now you mention it
it does give me comfort i can always
depend on drink
it takes away the pain i get comfortably
numb
i can come home and just block out or i
can come home and eat five doughnuts and
then i just go into this kind of soft
horrific place
and so
i don't treat the symptom which is i'm
eating cakes every day or drinking
alcohol or binging on netflix i'm i'm
using drugs i i treat what i call what
lies beneath why are you doing that what
does it give you when did you start that
why do you think it helps you i worked
with someone who was a chronic alcoholic
when i talked to him he said you know i
never saw my dad at 16 took me to the
pub and he got me drunk and he went
you're a man now and he began to take
him to the pub every weekend and i
thought this is great my dad
likes because i'm a man
and they had a very bonding time over
beer and then the dad died and he
continued drinking beer
because he believed that he was bonding
with his father even though he was dead
and so what was right about drinking
beer it has a memory
that's how my dad bonded with me in the
pub with his mates getting drunk
and so when you see oh so the role of
the drinking was to keep a memory going
yeah
but you can remember your dad he doesn't
live in a pint of beer you can think of
all the things you did do together
and you don't need to drink and so it's
it's coming to the realization that
something that we hate if something you
hate keeps coming back i keep dieting i
always gain the weight back i've been to
rehab eight times but i still keep
drinking
you got to stop treating the drinking
and treat the cause of the drinking the
role of the drinking the benefit of the
drinking the purpose of the drinking and
when you do that and get it right you
can change it forever like with ryan
who's never had a drink since he
realized that
he felt worthless because his father
rejected him because he was gay
and it starts with that awareness that
you described yeah and which is i i
think is such a difficult thing for some
people for many reasons i think some
people live in this kind of self-defense
state where they they didn't they
the awareness is too uncomfortable for
them to even contemplate yeah you know
i'm sure you've seen this in your
practice but either people don't want to
come yeah when they're there they don't
want to go to certain places yeah in
terms of they don't want to reveal
certain things they'd rather just ignore
opening that
that box
and live in you know a state of i don't
know
bliss naive bliss ignorance is bliss i
mean this there's a story in there of a
girl called terry who lost two babies
died one at birth one at a few weeks and
her two existed and one had a congenital
heart defect and the first thing she
said was don't take me back
i don't want to revisit that pain and i
said okay i won't i promise i won't so
while my job is to take people back i
call it being a good detective
someone's turned up and said well i i
don't know why i keep sabotaging i have
no idea i guess i'm just messed up
because i sabotage every relationship
every job i get i procrastinate and i
always get fired and i don't know why
so i've shut myself away and i don't
even want to look at that but you can
still go back and find it out because in
fact terry had a very functional all he
knew how to do was keep repairing itself
and she had a massive breakthrough just
in a half an hour conversation because
she understood
that being numb
[Music]
it's like you can't not feel but she was
living in a world of not feeling and it
was exhausting so
i always think what i do
wears three different hats the first hat
is michael being a good detective you're
an investigator you never say what's
wrong you say what happened
why do you feel like that why do you
want to change what would it look like
to change
i often say to people
straight away tell me about your family
i've got three says they're all great
it's just me or they might get oh
they're all messed up and then you know
straight away that something's gone very
wrong with his parenting or
something's just gone wrong with this
child
so when you put your investigator hat on
and you know a detective will lay out
images and look at them and go look at
that scene that's in that scene that
scene and they work out
what happened by looking at information
and a good rtt therapist is the same we
gather information
you have lots of aha moments lots of ear
prick up moments lots of things that
come up
that you think oh yeah i'm going to go
here i'm going to go there and after
you've done the investigating and found
out usually in minutes
why that person is the way they are you
then switch to almost being like a
dentist extracting all that toxic stuff
removing it
and finally become like a coder
it's like someone who's upgrading
someone's software and you code in and
wiring and firing
totally different beliefs but the skill
is doing it all at the same time many
people go to therapy and just talk about
what's wrong with me what's wrong with
me i don't know maybe i can find out and
others go
and maybe just do suggestion therapy but
let's give you a different belief but in
fact you have to do all three
seamlessly together because that's the
perfect recipe for change
i understand
i can let that understanding go and at
the same time i'm going to put in
something completely different
you know the with all these um a lot of
the sort of
mental health disorders you know
depression anxiety etc there's been a
lot said about the the recent and the
just apparent increase
in the amount of people reporting to
have these illnesses um do you believe
that there has been an increase and if
so what do you think has been the cause
i yeah i would say there's definitely an
increase in depression you know i've
found in my experience it's only my
experience that the major cause of
depression are a couple of things one
are harsh hurtful critical words that we
say to ourselves on a regular basis that
is guaranteed to make you depressed the
second is
being disconnected and we have an
epidemic of disconnection because
everyone is on their phone and their
screen
we worked from home in kobe some of us
are still doing that
we go to the store and we do a
self-checkout we go to the bank and we
check out with a machine so we are
becoming
disconnected and human beings are wired
for connection not disconnection
and the other thing i find as a massive
cause of depression is failing to follow
your heart's desire doing something
because well the family expect it the
pay is good
it's a solid job so those three things i
think are the massive cause of
depression
on that on that first point about people
telling themselves negative stories um
we'll all know people that are very
self-disparaging
is that and it's interesting because i
don't i mean they don't know where that
originates from but i know so many
people that are incredibly self
disparate yeah the first thing they'll
say to you is oh i'm sorry i look bad
today i know
i messed that up i'm just a mess
i always fail
i'm so sorry you know they look in the
mirror and they go oh my god look at me
or they go i'm going to do this but it
won't work
where it comes from funnily enough is is
our tribal need you know we're still
inside tribal people
and we need to connect with a group and
so bragging i'm better than you i'm
smarter than you i've got more than you
is disconnecting
and so people learn to connect by not
having that tall poppy center we have to
be the same you know children at school
bond by being the same
and i found many clients you know my
parents were rich or dirt poor i was the
only kid with glasses and i felt
different like being the head teacher's
daughter so it comes from there
so it's a strange thing that a few 100
years ago a few hundred years ago and
beyond
being negative
actually saved your life looking for
danger looking for snakes looking for
lions looking for weird people you might
do it because they believe it protects
them from hurt and pain if they reject
themselves first yes they reject
themselves first no one's ever going to
like me see i knew it
and now it doesn't hurt but it really
hurts
and so our job is to show people that no
happiness is there you might as well
expect the best you know muhammad ali
said i told myself i was the greatest
before i even was
and then something amazing and i became
the greatest he could have said i'm not
much good me i'm useless really it's all
a fluke but he said i am the greatest
long before he was
and that was so good for him because
people think of him as undefeated which
isn't true but that's the idea of him
because he
told himself a better lie
and if we could only all do that our
lives would be so much better mostly
because the mind doesn't know
or care if what you're telling it is
true or false or good or bad it just
lets it all in
it's like as you say you said uh you
know thoughts are actually blueprints
and i was thinking about about them as
like
they are
code going into a sat nav
yeah exactly if i tell myself i'm
beautiful and i'm going to be successful
and i'm going to get married then my
mind and my being will take me in that
direction maybe even subconsciously
my actions will further me in that
direction i will say yes to things that
are conducive with that
outcome um
and it really goes to show it doesn't it
the power of um yeah as you say
the limiting beliefs we tell ourselves
because we all say them i i've gone
through my life telling myself that i'm
really unorganized i know because yeah
because i grew up in a really
unorganized home where my parents were
over there so everything was just a mess
yeah and i'm not wanted or i don't
matter you know i was working with a kid
a couple of years ago who was in the
chelsea junior team chelsea football
club
and every day they're coaches you've got
a 2
chance of getting into the main team
playing just two percent you've got to
shape up
but you see most kids when they hear
that i think oh i got a 98 chance of
failing here two percent it's tiny i
said listen you just got to say
i'm in the two percent
someone else told me that their doctor
said you have a 20 chance of surviving
cancers that's great i'll go in i'm in
the 20
i'm in that 20 you might think that's
foolish but
when you set your mind to something
and look at being in the percentage that
makes it actually your mind and body
start to work at a level that make you
stay in that percentage
if you do the opposite well i'm in the
percentage of failures the same thing
happens your mind and body work to make
you stay in that percentage because
the strongest force in humans is that we
act in a way that totally matches how we
define ourselves when you say i'm a
loser i'm a hot mess i'm a train wreck
everything i touch doesn't work
if only we knew how we are making those
thoughts real
and how our mind's job is to actually
start making our thoughts real
we'd probably stop them
but but it's not i guess it's not so
easy just to make someone
an optimist yeah that's true if we think
about the pessimists in our lives and
i've i mean i've got friends that are
pessimistic about
they it just seems to be their default
and no matter i mean none of us in our
friendship group are therapists but the
efforts we've gone to to try and make
this individual
not pessimistic in every situation
have never ever worked thinking about
friend back home who
always and used to work for me who
always defaults to just pessimism and
everything's going wrong and whatever
and i you know
yeah but then you have to ask them what
if you say to them the same thing i say
to alcoholics what's good about it
they'd say i'm never disappointed what's
good about your pessimism yeah what's
good about it if i said to my mother
what's good about being a hypochondriac
she'd say well i get lots of attention
i love being in hospital everyone's so
worried about me people come to visit me
so you have to ask what's good about
being a pessimistic and he'll say
i don't let people down
people don't expect anything of me
and so it's that expectation yeah and
it's a little bit more than the thought
because if you imagine a snack i have to
use my fingers to explain it that's the
thought
and thought always comes first
and then you think a thought when you
think a thought you then feel a feeling
and then the feeling dictates how you
act so imagine you thought of thought
which is i'm not enough
the biggest cause of um issues in the
western world is this not enoughness if
i thought i'm not enough
and i went straight to the next ladder
the next stage how would i feel if i
thought not enough i'd feel sad
dejected demoralized maybe angry
maybe resentful maybe bitter so i've
thought of thought i got some feelings
that come with thinking the thought but
then what actions come from thinking
that thought and feeling these feelings
often no actions i don't take risks i
don't ask people out ask for promotion
i'm actually angry and defensive so now
i've got actions and behaviors
i'm angry i'm defensive i'm
reclusive i'm a loser
i don't bother and then we justify it by
going back because i'm not enough but if
you switch that to i am enough and just
took out they're not go okay if i
thought of jam enough if i said it even
if i didn't believe it but said it said
it said it
what would i feel well i might feel
optimistic i might feel confident i
might feel reassured i might feel
hopeful i might feel excited
and then what thought actions would i
have well i would take some risks i'd
i'd ask people out i'd ask for that
promotion i'd follow my dreams i behaved
differently and i justify again it's
like a loop
thought feeling action behavior thought
so although it sounds very pollyanna oh
you're just thinking great thoughts it's
much more than that because when you
think a thought
you feel a feeling and then you act on
that thought and feeling and you behave
in a way that's linked to that thought
and feeling and a lot of things so let's
change the behavior stop drinking stop
smoking stop sabotaging stop
procrastinating stop acting out
but the behavior is the last thing to
change you have to go back and change
the thought first
and then it's easy does the thought or
that or like the underlying belief come
from some kind of subjective evidence or
experience we've had in our life i
always think about all my beliefs and i
always think that they are all based on
some whether right or wrong whether true
or false evidence
so
you know i struggled with relationships
i've talked about that on this podcast
but i struggled with relationships and
that meant that i was avoidant even if i
was attracted to someone even if i
pursued someone the minute they asked to
commit to me i would dissuade them and
tell them all the reasons why we should
not be together um and i and i look back
and and my childhood and really the
evidence that was at the center of my
belief was watching my parents screaming
at each other every day really awfully
yeah this belief that my dad was in
prison that i always had and i was
trying to bail him out of prison from my
mum screaming at him yeah so the way
that i viewed it was once i became aware
of this faulty evidence i had in my life
from my childhood honestly from writing
and doing this podcast it finally dawned
on me where i'd learned what love and
was and how identical the feeling i felt
about being imprisoned was
similar to the seven of six-year-old
steve looking at his dad being screamed
down
so for me
what i thought happened was i became
aware and then the awareness of it
allowed me to not
the trigger which would be someone
asking me to be in a relationship with
them no longer held enough power over me
which allowed me to get into a
relationship to rewrite new year's
because really you stop thinking the
thought that a relationship is a prison
that's what it really goes back to you
began to understand that you weren't
born with that thought you acquired it
and anything you require you can release
so you worked out oh i've been seeing
this with the filter of a six-year-old a
six-year-old filter says
a relationship is like prison especially
for a man but then you realized you
weren't six
and there's lots of other evidence that
says that's not true
and you changed your thought you see
when you question the belief you don't
believe it that's why in religion you
may not question the priest or the abbot
or the immense not allowed to do that
because we understand
when you question a belief you begin to
doubt it that's why people are deeply
religious never question it i know god
exists how do you know i just know when
you question a belief like when you see
your children my little girl saying
mommy but how does father christmas get
down how does the reindeer get down the
chimney they're that big and the
chimney's that big and how can you get
all around the world in one night and no
they're beginning to doubt which is a
great thing so if you question a belief
you introduce doubt
and that's what a great therapist does
it says really
oh are you always a failure
were you really meant to be an
accountant to please your dad is that
why you're here on the planet do you
really think that everything you touch
fails do you really believe there's no
one in the world that can love you do
you so when you start getting people to
question beliefs you open up a little
glimmer of oh
right
yeah that doesn't have to be true and it
doesn't have to be true for me and
that's why it's important
which you did so eloquently you looked
at the belief of a six-year-old and
thought
but that's not me one of the things i i
talk about in the book a lot is having
clients say that's not me because
and they have to justify why that isn't
them
oh that kid that wore second-hand
clothes and
mum was never there that isn't me i've
got a wardrobe full of clothes i don't
have to do that anymore but you know we
we play the only part we've ever known
and then we make that part our own and
we don't even know that there's many
other parts we could take on
if we wanted to
even those beliefs that that that
imprisonment belief that i had in
relationships with prison
i i felt it the power of that belief
didn't deteriorate over time good but i
still believe that it's there somewhere
and i that kind of makes me wonder if
those very sort of deeply held childhood
beliefs ever really completely vanish or
if they are still capable of being
triggered so for example if if i was in
a relationship now
and my girlfriend started say shouting
at me in the same way my dad shouted at
my mum
i could very well see myself just
getting up and leaving
not shouting back just getting up and
leaving trying to like flee
flee the jail
and i i just wonder with these you know
even with your the clients that you have
and the patients you see whether they
really ever fully overcome
i think a lot of them do i think it's a
work in progress it's about
you look to that little boy who said
relationships are prison and you realize
that was a statement that for you as a
statement of truth it wasn't a question
it was a statement and then what you
have to do is start making a different
statement the mind learns by repetition
relationships are wonderful people say
to me marriage is such hard work i'm
like i don't think so i found it hard
being single i got the flu i got to get
out of bed go to the pharmacist myself
make myself some soup in a marriage in a
relationship someone else said hey i'll
get that i'll do that let me do that so
you question the belief that you have it
then you have to also change it and you
have to keep repeating
the changes you know i worked with
somebody once who said
i have no coping skills my mother was
hypersensitive to lighter noise i
couldn't open a packet of potato chips
without her going mental
we never went to the cinema or the
swimming pool or the beach she didn't
like light she didn't like noise she
didn't like people
and then she said and i have no coping
skills and i made her say i want you to
say i have phenomenal coping skills and
so she had to say that every day she
didn't believe it but she said you know
it's amazing
i say that every day and i've become
this person who feels she can cope with
anything
so you have to look at your question
your statement
and just change it i don't matter i
matter i'm insignificant i'm signing i'm
not lovable i am lovable i'm not enough
i've always been enough and if every
person in the world could wake up and
just say
i matter i'm significant i'm enough and
i'm lovable
that would change my i know that to be
true because i've got many anti-bullying
programs in schools all of them they all
say the same thing
all the kids say they're dumb enough
they've made a little plaque for their
desk and bullying has almost disappeared
in this school
just from those simple statements
because
bullies don't feel enough it isn't
enough to work with a bully child you
must work with a kid who's doing the
bullying what's going on with them
nobody says oh my life is so great so
wonderful who can i bully today i'm
having a great time i think i'll go off
and troll somebody
so we know that
they're not enough this is the core of
so many of our beliefs but
since the mind doesn't know or care what
you're saying
if you switch i'm not enough to i am
enough
the shift isn't subtle it's profound
just the subtlety of words you seem to
um
assert that it makes a tremendous
difference just one word that we use
just one word because we go through our
lives saying things so we go through
life i'll say like you know i'm not
organized or i'll say i can't do that um
you know and a lot of the time the truth
is i probably could but
if we're in this culture of just the
flippancy of words where we say i can't
that's not me
i'm not that person i am this these kind
of like binary definitive statements
are they dangerous
yeah when you say somehow they go not
bad i'm all right
how was your weekend not bad so they
they're really minimizing anything
that's good and i think you have to turn
it right up but
often the one word many years ago one of
my clients said i wish you'd see my
mother she has a hell of a life with my
dad he hits her he's aggressive but
she's very invested in
you know the front of a marita in came
this sweet little old lady
and she kept talking about her husband
saying he's a good husband said but he's
not a good husband darling he's a good
provider i want you to switch the word
husband to provider
because he hits you he's abusive he
diminishes you that's not a good husband
but he is a good provider i know that's
important you've got a nice home
three kids you went all left so she
began to say he's a good provider she
said you know it's amazing i went home
within three months i divorced him
because i thought oh well i don't need
to be with a provider i've already got
this house i've got my pension so for
her that one word
he's only been a good provider in my
entire marriage and he's actually hurt
me a lot and do i need him to provide
i've got a pension i've got a house i've
got friends i got my children he can't
provide anything i can't provide myself
she's not a good husband at all and so
for her just taking off the blinkers and
having someone tell her the truth
that's not love isn't that crazy love
doesn't hurt like that people say oh
my boyfriend loves me so much he hits me
that's not love
you may believe it's love it's passion
it's not love my dad
hits me because i don't behave that's
not love and often you have to educate
people in a very nice way
and change one word i'm useless no
you're smart
i don't matter you matter a great deal
and going back again to all these
teenage kids who say no one loves me i
don't matter i go look if your life was
a clock
you're talking about the first five
minutes of the clock the first five
minutes is horrible but you've got the
whole rest of the clock to have an
amazing life you know you this is your
life today but it's not your life your
life today is you're being bullied at
school your parents don't seem to care
and no one's there and that's horrible
for you but and that is your life but
it's not your life
your life's going to be amazing and then
you have to help them stand up to
bullies and believe they matter and not
tolerate it but it all starts again
you know there's a great song called it
started with a kiss but nothing starts
it starts with a thought about a kiss
everything goes back to a thought and if
you can keep peeling back to the thought
like your thought marriage is prison
then you think but i have the power to
change that thought at any stage no
matter how long down the line is
if you change the thought
you change everything because the law of
control begins with thoughts you can't
control the weather or the traffic you
can't even control your body you'd never
get a cold but you can always control
your thoughts and when you control your
thoughts
it changes your whole life and i know it
sounds easy or simple but that's because
it is simple
you know i've been doing this
five day challenge in schools and it's
called the i can't to i can
and it's just five days where every day
these children go from i can't do i can
they have an imaginary cheerleader that
does somersaults and bangs symbols and
cheers them on and they've all said
it's made such a difference because they
realize they can
that when you say i can't what if nobody
likes you what if i fail what if i get
it wrong well you might but you also
might get it right and if you get it
wrong
you've learned something you know you
you can if you never make a mistake
you've never made anything because the
only way you can learn is often by
getting it wrong you think oh i tried
that i didn't like it i never want to do
that again
we're now playing in a world where the
digital landscape is changing every
single day and to succeed as a small
business the most important thing you
can do is stay informed with the latest
trends and that's why i've partnered
with vodafone business they genuinely
want to help small businesses like you
navigate this fast moving space they've
developed the v hub a site containing
everything you need to get up to speed
with what's going on and you can even
ring up a vhub digital advisor for
completely free and have a one-on-one
conversation with them about your
business if you haven't checked out the
v hub i'd highly recommend you do so as
it will help your business navigate the
changing landscape and keep you on the
front foot so go to vhub by vodafone you
can search that anywhere on google and
check it out now
being a therapist and speaking to
a wide variety of people you must also
face some pretty heartbreaking
outcomes and cases tell me about one
that comes to mind when i say that i
think my saddest case was a
boy of 14 his father was very physical
with him but he lived with a mother
and
he didn't have any skills to handle that
so he became very violent at school and
was being expelled
and when i saw him i said darling your
dad's not allowed to put his hands on
you you know that he said but i can't
answer but you can stop him you have to
so he practiced rehearsing a lot that he
would say to his dad you may not put
your hands on me
and then i said i think you have to not
see him for a little while and then the
mother said but he needs a dad i said
well not like that that's hitting him
with a belt nobody needs that and he
does need a dad but he needs a dad that
respects him so we had to all have this
little family conversation that they
were going to go home and ring him and
so i can't see you until you get help
and the father was so childish he
smashed up his xbox and dumped it in the
garden
but he didn't see me stood his ground
and then the father wanted to see him
and i said you know every time you must
say to me can i put your hands in if you
do
i can't stop you when i leave i will
call the police because
i gotta get you some help you you can't
be like this and actually was amazing i
did feel sorry for that kid because the
father was so dismissive but eventually
the father realized that the only way he
could see him
was to stop being violent because
i had to give this little boy the power
you're only 14 but you're smarter than
your dad you're more educated than your
dad you're more grown up and your dad is
a child
and you have to be the man here and say
i won't let you hit me because it's
damaging for you as well as me
and often with kids it's giving them a
voice giving them the power to say no
when someone is abusing them molesting
them taking their lunch money
you know and that's often the case so
many kids just don't have the power to
say no
because when they said they said don't
you say no to me when people say to me
my kid's so annoying i said that's how
they learn i mean my kid argued with me
all the time
and i always think i'm secretly rather
pleased that she could stand up for
herself and defend herself and wasn't a
yes person
and we forget when we won't let our kids
have a say
they go into the world and they don't
know how to have a say and that's a
terrible injustice for them
i was reading in your book about
children and just more broadly about the
the um
some of the mistakes parents make when
they're raising children and one of them
as you kind of cited earlier was about
um telling them not to feel
things right so if you fall over
don't cry don't cry be a big boy stop
being a baby that's definitely what i
had planned to do with my kids yeah tell
me why i'm wrong
yeah you know i i said to my girl but
don't don't be a base because mummy i am
a baby and i thought my god she's so
smart she is a baby because she was my
teacher and then i remembered to say to
when she hurt her leg oh
that really hurt didn't it ouch that
hurt she goes yes mommy it hurt but then
she'd be okay but when you said don't
cry you're a big girl now that didn't
hurt stop making a fuss what you're
saying is don't feel your feelings
swallow them push them down pretend
you're okay put on a happy face and if
you'll walk through the world and say
well i can't tell anyone what i'm
feeling because we've trained them in
the same way we train kids to finish
everything on their plate
one of the best gifts you can give your
children is letting them feel you know
that hurt
you're a great kid but today you're
being really mean she says what's going
on and then let's say you said she was
my favorite
years ago i took my little daughter we
were lambing and she pushed my nipple
and pushed him off a haystack and my
brother was very crossed i said why did
you do that she said you said he was
your favorite i said no
said he was my favorite nephew you're my
favorite you'll always be my favorite
he's my favorite nephew and you cannot
do that and you have to go and apologize
and she did
but i was really quite pleased that i
was able to say what just happened then
you can't always do that sometimes you
have to intervene but
good kids do bad things smart kids do
stupid things and rather than saying
you're so annoying or naughty or bad you
say what's going on
what made why did you just do that and
they'll tell you something that you
would never
expect and then
then they feel safe sharing what's going
on and it
you you children need you to be their
safe place they need to come to you and
say hey my friend's taking drugs my
little homage to his mum my friend's
brother we went out
and he's much bigger and he was stealing
all these baseball hats and he made me
wear i didn't want to wear one i said oh
that's your feelings telling you it's
wrong you must always listen to those
feelings and when that happens again you
must say
my i don't feel i can wear that baseball
hat
and so
i was very pleased that she come in and
tell me stuff about drugs and sex and
shoplifting and some of this literally
your eyes literally pop out on stalks
but you have to not judge your kids it's
it's very
easy to say not so easy to do but you
just have to
take a deep breath even if you know the
time and ask them
what's going on
there's something that i i sort of
garnered from all of that which i'm i
think is really applicable to business
and generally like leadership and
i guess friendship as well which was
typically we we come with answers and we
come with statements
whereas the approach you seem to take
even with your your daughter there is
much more question-centric it's asking
questions and being kind of
removed from having a bias or
presumption so and i was thinking about
that from a leadership perspective if
you when there's an issue in your
business with with an employee or
something instead of
coming with statements and presumptions
it's probably wiser to come with a
question at first
yeah what's going on i was like said
that to my pa there they didn't i just
am overwhelmed by something in my
personal life so when you can say
something you know what's going on or
yeah it's it's easier you know
i was meeting my daughter in london
recently i hadn't seen her for ages i
was so excited she turned up at this
restaurant she was in a really bad mood
and i said do you wanna and i don't like
that do you want to go no i hate that
and and i i'm i felt like saying you
know what i'm just gonna go home i don't
know why i've come here but i just said
well
anything you know i don't like anything
here and then i said well let's order a
coffee so she and then she says mommy
i'm so glad that you understand me
because it's not you i've had a big
fight with someone and i'm in such a bad
temper
and i was just being really defensive
and i felt great too because i learned
to not think
how dare she talk to me like that i
might as well go home i thought oh
something's going on with her why don't
i just sit here
drink my own coffee and just wait for
her to work it out so if you can sit
with someone and not judge them
and say
i mean everything officers didn't want
it but i just left that
then usually they'll tell you what's
wrong but you can't interrogate people
and sometimes you just have to give them
a little while to come around but
i think when you stop judging people
which isn't always easy
[Music]
amazing when you have a workforce that
mess up or
a super defensive you you know try that
so this is going to try a little
tenderness because you get much better
results you know my husband and i have
this great thing where i say
oh what's the story you're telling
yourself one day we were driving in the
car
and i think i was driving and he was on
his phone i was talking he wasn't
listening i talked again and i went oh
i'm telling myself a story here that
you're not interested in anything i have
to say and he went oh that's really
funny because i'm telling myself a story
that you're annoying me because i've
just got a message from our accountant
saying our our account's been hacked and
i'm feeling really panicking and i'm
looking at this message and you're yeah
yeah so we both i'm telling myself a
story that you're not allowing me space
to read this very important message now
my story is
you're not listening but i told that on
a podcast and this girl wrote and she
said well he was wrong he was definitely
having an affair because
banks don't write to say being hacked in
fact
it was our accountant that sent him a
text saying you've been hacked
but that was so funny because there was
a third story in there someone else's
story which was oh he's definitely
cheating on you because
and so i thought that was so funny that
didn't upset me because we all tell
ourselves the story you don't love me
anymore you forgot my birthday you don't
give me the attention you used to
you're not interested in me
the significant shift there as well is
responsibility yeah you're even in the
car example like i s it sounds like a
conversation i had with my girlfriend
recently where i was trying to do
something and she tries telling me
something i'm
going through a crisis on my phone
and i'm telling myself that she doesn't
understand my world and she's whatever
and she's telling herself that i'm i
never listen to her and she's saying
important things
thankfully because i i'm in a slightly
more mature phase of my life we're able
to have the conversation yeah as you've
described where i'd say this is how i
felt and i was telling myself this yeah
you know
but a lot of people don't do that blame
is much feels much easier and it takes a
certain type of maturity in person to
even be able to take responsibility
in the first place i tend to believe
that people who are
who have i don't know if this is
accurate it's just a belief i have but
um that have like lower self-esteem are
less capable of allowing themselves to
look in the mirror and take
responsibility for things yeah they are
the most like protective of yeah they're
much
more adept at blaming refusing to budge
because they believe that
if you're right they're wrong
it is easy to be defensive and blaming
and never admit you're wrong because we
think being wrong means that we're weak
you know it's why men will never say i'm
lost because if you're a hunter you are
useless to the tribe if you say i'm lost
i don't even know how to find my way
back
and so it's the
it's the fear of being wrong and but how
to get around and say listen here's the
truth you're flawed i'm flawed the best
we can ever be in the world
is two flawed people having a flawed
relationship i call it being floorsome
so if you can decide hey i like being
flawed you know i tell all my clients
the unhappiest people i've ever worked
with without a shadow of a doubt
are the ones who try to be perfect and
they're always the loneliest too
because they can never say they're wrong
it's always your fault you did it you
made them
but if you can't be wrong you're going
to be alone because the basis of all
friendship is as we choose people
who share our vulnerabilities if you
haven't got any then you also won't have
any friends
so it is a defensive mechanism to never
admit you're wrong it can very hard to
say no i was wrong
better to say i made a mistake i messed
up i didn't handle that very well i saw
my husband's daughter once say you know
i messed up death i was so proud of it
so i messed up that i didn't handle
myself well at all
really sorry but that p you go up in
someone's estimation when you can do
that we all know when bill clinton
apologized people liked him more yeah
they didn't they'd like him lesbians i
didn't do anything wrong yeah
so the fear of being wrong
creates a lot of problems especially in
teenagers until we can say look
even in the bible it says to er is human
to forgive is divine i always think to
her as human but it feels divine
so we have to not punishable for making
mistakes especially our own kids or
partners say look yeah you did mess up
but
it's okay i'm glad you recognized that
and
i felt like this when
it all comes back again to can you
communicate
and you have healthy self-esteem because
people with healthy steam will say i was
wrong i made a mistake that was my error
people
with low self-esteem said no it was your
fault
it was all your fault
so true and i think that point about
how you go up in people's self-esteem
when you take responsibility is so
unbelievably true because that's what it
means responsibility means an ability to
respond that's what it is it's an
ability to respond and we want to have
an ability to respond better it's
incredibly trust building as well isn't
it when when you know that someone is
able to say
like i'm responsible for that or i made
a mistake here yeah it kind of
allows you to understand that they are
self-analytical and
that they can
um
they can be left to
yeah assess themselves and also some
people just want to be heard when they
go to their mother and say you know you
really hurt me they go well what about
my life you know you had them and it
then they don't feel heard so when your
kid or your husband or your wife comes
in or your friend and says you really
hurt me when you forgot my birth they
all
forgot about how important that was or
cancel the last minute you have to say
oh yeah
i hear that i'm really sorry i heard
even if you think they're being
ridiculous you still have to i hear that
that hurt you
and i'm sorry that hurt you
because
being heard is so important to us when
we feel heard
we feel valuable and we feel significant
you know again our needs are to feel
significant and worthy and enough
so if you can hear someone you make them
feel significant and worthy enough and
if you don't hear them go oh you're just
being over dramatic you're overreacting
not that again why don't you just get
over yourself then you don't feel
significant you don't feel worthy and
you don't feel heard so
we want to have higher self-esteem and
if you can tell people oh yeah i can
hear how i upset you i really feel bad
about that you're growing
there's significance
and then when you can feel heard
you feel more significant too so it's
such a gift to give someone just hearing
them and even if it doesn't make sense
to you still saying yeah i i get it you
feel like that i'm really sorry
in your book when you're going through
the case study of joe i believe it was
you talking a lot about food and diet
yeah
we all have the belief and even i do and
i work out every day pretty much every
day about six days a week and even i
know who i want to be in terms of my
diet i know that i want to lose fat i
know that i want to not eat the pringles
i'm very clear on this i think about it
a lot but i still eat the pringles and i
still have the chocolate and i still
don't seem to be able to
live in accordance with what i know or
at least what i say
um i want to do and also as you've
articulately said we all know
what good food and bad food is
but we still continue to make the wrong
choices
but from an evolutionary point of view
sugar is a good food you know if you
were living thousands of years ago and
you're out on the prairie
if you found honey or fruit it was
probably going to be very safe and had a
lot of fructose and it would keep going
if you found some lettuce that wouldn't
be the same and bitter stuff was wanted
to poison you so we're actually a hard
wired to prefer sugar because it gives
us a lot of nutri a lot of calories
a lot of energy
for something small whereas
something else wouldn't do that
and our primitive brain still believes
it will run out of sugar which is why no
one says i've got that lettuce in the
fridge calling whenever that ben and
jerry's that cake those cookies i keep
going back for more and so it's very
hard to fight your primitive wiring you
are hard watch remember where sugar is
and finish it you're hardwired to eat
food when you see it because
if the hunters came home with some
fish and you said i don't really fancy
fish two days later you would be kicking
yourself because you should have eaten
it when it was in front of you we're
wired to be scared of hunger if you're
scared of hunger you can't be rational
also wired to go for fat you know so
pringles and potato chips are the new
cigarettes because we love the fat we
love the crunch because we have stress
receptors here that love biting and
crunching
[Music]
and so everything we think was wrong
about food is actually from our minds
but no it's right you should eat when
you seafood you should load up on
calorific food because we lived in a
feast and famine for years but if you
can understand it you can change it and
the whole diet industry is based on
absolute abuse and self-hatred you know
we talk about punishing those pounds
doing a punishing workout living on a
shake diet or
powdered soup diet that just tastes
disgusting
we go to
um groups where we get weighed and
shamed in front of people we talk about
food as sins and we've had a naughty day
or i've been good i've been so good i
haven't now been really bad i ate a
cookie and
that that is why to make you feel like a
massive massive failure even you saying
i shouldn't eat the pringles i shouldn't
eat the chocolate you know the way
you eat is only down to the pictures you
make in your head
if the picture's right you eat is why
vegans can't eat meat because the
picture is wrong jewish people can't eat
pork because the picture is wrong so if
you want to succeed you've got to
maybe set fire to some pringles or
do something make some glue with jelly
sweets and then when you make the
picture different you'll never want to
eat it again but you can't
succeed at that by beating yourself up
that's so very true the thing that
stopped me drinking coke was watching a
clip that someone had shared and it they
just boiled coke
they showed the residue that was left
behind and it looked like oil yeah and
this picture i have in my head now is
that if i drink coke i'm putting this
gloopy black oil in yeah and i'm scared
of that the way you feel about
everything everything is down to
only two things the pictures you make in
your head
and the words you say to yourself and i
think i've now trained thirteen thousand
therapists in rtt all over the world and
they all say you know that that's such a
condensing therapy into a moment
the way you feel is down to the pictures
you make and the words you control which
you are free to change i can't get on a
plane it's killing it's dangerous well
actually the most dangerous part is the
cab ride to the airport
it's a state of mind
they feel free
and so if you can just look at every
time you think of something or feel
something think what are the pictures
and words what am i saying
and if you can change them it changes
everything and of course they are your
words and pictures
i'm going on a date i might be rejected
but i could be with someone amazing who
just thinks i'm the most amazing thing
i'm going this i could fail but i could
also get this amazing job of my dreams
we've all been told that human beings
are very complicated and that the mind
is very complex that it isn't it's very
simple you only have to know three
things about your mind one is
the way you feel about anything is down
to the pictures you make in your head
and the words you say the second is that
your mind is hardwired to keep returning
to what's familiar
while running away from what's
unfamiliar which and that's true but you
can make anything you can put a bit of
silicone on your finger and shove it in
your eye every day and it becomes so
familiar but at first using lenses is
very unfamiliar
but most important thing about the mind
is that it does what it thinks you want
and you've got to sit down and think you
know but what do i want i wanted
tensions i've got a nervous twitch i
want attention i'm getting all these
illnesses oh i see i should have sent
said i want
positive attention for being really
smart or
really kind or really evolved so
really you don't need to study in human
being you need to know those three
things and if you know them and apply
them you can make sense of your life and
everyone else lives but also you can
make your life so much better by
thinking i can change the pictures
i can take sugar out of my coffee and
make it familiar very quickly and if i
tell my mind like a spice girl what i
really really really want but i'm very
clear
like you know i want more money well
what's that 10 bucks i want
passionate relationship for how long a
week so if you just keep always going
back to those three things and and
looking at them you can have whatever
you want
once you can look at those three things
and make them work for you
and not against you when i talked about
the pringles there you talked about the
kind of
this initial stage being that acceptance
of understanding that this is my hard
wiring
um and this is you know i'm not
i'm not a bad human in fact i am a human
you're doing what nature wants you to do
actually yeah and that acceptance is um
you talk about it when you talk about
terry in your book when you're talking
about dealing with hard feelings this
triple a
sort of process can you give me a little
bit of illumination on that yeah i love
triple a i invented that a lot of things
i invent is first of all makes it easy
for me but when i'm teaching therapists
it's easy with everything triple a what
does that mean it means
be aware of what you're feeling so this
is a formula almost a three-step process
for dealing with hard feelings so any
hard feelings or indeed any feelings
don't even have to be hard um be aware
of what you're feeling
and accept it that's the second people
think what am i feeling i'm feeling
jealous i shouldn't feel jealous i need
to eat a cake i'm feeling a feeling in
my stomach the seat of all emotions and
i
shouldn't really feel that feeling let
me eat it drink it smoke it shop it
netflix it but when you say i'm gonna be
aware
i'm aware that i'm feeling incredibly
jealous
of someone else whose book is selling
more than mine oh i feel really jealous
about that
now i've got to accept it yeah i'm
feeling a little envious but you know
what my book's doing good not as good as
theirs but i got to accept it then i've
got to articulate it
i got to say out loud
i'm feeling really a little envious
about that paul mckenna got so much
bigger numbers maybe you know paul
deserves it he's worked really hard he's
not me i'm not here my books are
different
and if you can just do that triple a
always start with the awareness what am
i feeling people say oh you shouldn't
feel that you go well but my feelings
are the most real thing i have how can i
not feel it
i was having a conversation i said we
shouldn't feel that i'm like
shouldn't feel it the feelings are re i
can't not feel it it's like saying you
shouldn't be diabetic
so first of all
i'm feeling it and you can't tell me i
can't feel it because i'm feeling it so
i'm aware i'm feeling it and i'm going
to accept that i'm feeling it
and then i'm going to articulate right
now i'm feeling this rage towards my
boss who's
taken my idea and passed and i'm feeling
this rage towards my sister or my
partner because they're not listening to
me
so i'm aware i accept i articulate but
if you do those three it goes away
because feelings like children going hey
notice me
and if you don't notice and they regroup
and become stronger when you eat your
feelings shop your feelings
netflix or drink or drug your feelings
they don't go away they regroup and come
back but when you feel them
when you
are aware of them and you accept them
and you articulate and they actually go
away really quickly so many people come
in and say i just feel
so angry so sad so frustrated so
disappointed
well
okay let's feel that right now and let's
say it out loud and then then it will go
away and if only we all knew that it
makes such a difference to our life you
see it in men don't you men express
themselves the least and kill themselves
the most yeah the highest suicide rate
in the world
is young men and actually they always
someone has always made them wrong it's
always someone who's made them wrong
before they take that action someone has
made them wrong wrong yeah someone has
made them wrong someone else has been
right and they feel very wrong they've
been dumb they've been rejected they've
failed
at some exam they've been humiliated
they feel wrong
but yeah and and but they don't feel
that they're allowed to have those
feelings you know men don't cry you're
running like a girl stop being a big
girl's blouse we have all these
expressions for men man up
and all they say is don't feel
and and that's killing people not
feeling it's you know we've got people a
glut of people taking
antidepressants to be numb because they
don't want to feel and yet your feelings
are the most real thing you have and
they will do you an immense favor if you
tune into them
sometimes you think you know what am i
feeling actually i'm feeling really
nervous i'm about to give a speech and
i'm feeling kind of nervous what can i
do well i can remember that i always
feel like that before a speech but i
always do them and
in five minutes it will all pass it will
be gone and i'm just talking myself into
it instead of talking myself out of it
so i'm going to accept i feel nervous
i'm aware of it and i'm going to say oh
yeah here's that old nervous feeling
again actually it's adrenaline it's
excitement
and i always get this and it's always
gone
you can always talk yourself into
something or out of it
took yourself out of the negative into
the positive ones it will change your
entire life
incredibly incredibly inspiring and um
i relate to a lot of that um we have a
um
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast okay
where the previous guest writes the
question for the next guest okay how
cool so the previous guest has written
you a question they didn't know who they
were writing it for
okay
um i won't tell you who they are okay
you're gonna have to riddle this one a
little bit but the question is are you
experienced question mark
if so what did you learn
and then they've done an asterisk at the
bottom that says in the jimi hendrix
sense
oh i lost love jimi hendrix are you
experienced yeah i am experienced you
know people say to me but you're not a
doctor
you're not a psychology not a
psychiatrist but i've been a therapist
for 35 years my entire adult life and
i feel i am very experienced in
understanding human pain and what did i
learn i learned that almost all my
clients pain comes from not believing
they're enough it's why i have all these
i'm enough braces why i created the i'm
enough movement because i worked with
millionaires
and olympic athletes and sports stars
and movie stars and i realized they have
the same problems so
what my experience taught me from
starting as a therapist working with you
know everyday people school teachers and
police officers and stay-at-home moms to
working with
billionaires taught me that we're all
the same and we all have the same core
issue i just don't feel enough but that
isn't true
but if you keep saying it it becomes
true because it feels true
and so if we can just change those
thoughts and feelings so my experience
taught me that
therapy is not complicated and it taught
me that this belief oh someone's got
depression that's very complex so the
treatment's complex too no it isn't
treatment
can be really fast and effective because
it comes from again the not enoughness
it's so insidious
but it's not even real but it's like
saying my headache is psychosomatic that
doesn't mean it doesn't hurt it's just
the same as a headache that's caused by
an exposure to toxic fevers they both
hurt the same
one is real one is psychosomatic but
they feel the same
and so my experience taught me to treat
people
and to simplify simplify therapy
simplify the cure
you know the word cure comes from the
word curious and if you're curious
and if you treat every client as if they
are fascinating and compelling and
interesting you'll always unravel in
your curiosity i mean we're not allowed
to say we cure people but still i love
the fact that cure
comes from the word curious
marissa thank you so much and thank you
for writing such a brilliant book
the first time i've read a book like
this that was centered around case
studies of patients
because you're telling real stories um
of patients and really dissecting them
it's much easier to follow and to relate
to than if you were just like you know
if it was a textbook because i read
those textbooks in school the the
childhood psychology textbooks and
psychology textbooks they were difficult
yeah the diagrams and stuff but this
felt very very human and i think that's
what made it yeah i wanted people to
think i identify with terry i identify
with joe and if i see terry's story i
can see my story and in terry's um
transformation i can see how to
transform me because we all relate so
exactly i wanted people to relate to it
and get the same benefit it's a very
different approach but it's an
incredibly powerful one and i think it's
an incredibly important book for
everybody to read thank you as well
because you know your your work
influenced my my first book in a big way
and just the job when i saw that clip um
going viral online where you talked
about people not feeling like they're
enough
it was exactly what i'd felt for my my
whole childhood and it was really just
an illuminating thing that allowed me to
behave in a different way and cure some
of my own sort of
um
insecurities shall i say yeah thank you
so the simpleness of it was the people
think if it's simple
it can't be profound but the strength
often is in the very simplicity and it
can be so profound so yeah it's always
easy when it's simpler thank you i'm so
pleased and touched that i could help
you
not just me
yeah many many millions yeah thank you
marissa thank you too it's been lovely
thank you
[Music]
it's one of the most amazing things in
my life that i get to do a podcast which
of course needs money to to fuel and i
have a sponsor like your who i genuinely
believe is going to help every single
person
who starts their heel journey change
their life it's such an incredible
product and for me the reason why it's
incredible is because it gives me my
protein it gives me my vitamins minerals
it's plant-based it's low in sugar
gluten free if you haven't tried you'll
give it a try and if you do
tag me instagram wherever you try it
give me a tag
as you might know crafted are one of the
sponsors of this podcast and they make
really meaningful pieces of jewellery
this lion piece they've made i wear all
the time along with the little timepiece
the sand timer that i wear often for me
the lion has always been an animal that
can be almost a bit of a contradiction
they are so loving and so caring of
their own and can be powerful and
courageous when necessary in order to
achieve what they want to achieve so if
you like me are a big fan of courage
bravery ambition while also being
calm and composed check out this line
piece and let me know if you get it
[Music]
so
[Music]